good morning everyone
for us this is a a day to
acknowledge great accomplishments for
the american people
when american people voted for a
democratic white house and democratic
majorities
in the congress we promised help
is on the way and now help
is here democrats have been living for
the people
to build back better passing the
american rescue plan to crush the
coronavirus
and defeat the economic crisis including
with the biden
child tax cut binding
because credit for some it really is a
tax
cut for all passing landmark lines
laws for equal pay empowering workers
lowering health care costs creating jobs
rebuilding the infrastructure and more
thanks to the democratic leadership the
build back better economy
is working it's working thank you mr
president
jobs are coming back going from 60 000
jobs
every month to 60 thousand jobs every
three days thirty days three days
and one tenth to the time sixty thousand
jobs wages are rising pay
checks are growing at the strongest rate
in fifteen years the economy
is booming yesterday you saw the economy
grow
at the fastest rate in nearly 40 years
families are benefiting poverty is set
to be cut in half
this year with the share of americans
living in poverty set to reach the
lowest level
on record but to sustain this growth for
years to come and ensure ensure
that we can then uh share in its
benefits that all can share in its
benefits
we need to be transformative in terms of
how we go forward with infrastructure
investments
and reconciliation bills that truly meet
families needs
we will build back better with more jobs
cut taxes
and lower costs for all we're proud to
be here with our dazzling
chairs of the committees who made so
much of this possible
uh you'll be hearing from leader cindy
hoyer with jim clyburn
assistant speaker catherine clark and
our
committee chair stan ready uh to answer
any questions about what is that right
now we are
celebrating record-breaking accomplished
accomplishments
on passage of the appropriations bills
thanks to the virtuoso performance of
our
great chair rosa delauro we are
uh just so grateful to frank pallone for
in every one of the bills for the last
year and a half
that he has been there to help with
crushing the virus
and now truly doing so and actually
having an impact on the infrastructure
legislation as well our chair peter
defazio
is the just a maestro at all of this
he he knows issues that relate to
infrastructure
better than anyone he's been at it for
decades
on the committee of jurisdiction and now
so proudly for all of us as its chairman
but he also knows how to save the planet
and the combination of those two is
absolutely essential
at this at this time and richie neil my
goodness
everything goes through richie neal's
committee thank you for the child tax
cut thank you for so many other things
that i'm sure you will tell us about
richie said you know everybody goes out
and makes
investments and then comes to us to pay
for them we want to
we want to initiate some of our own
ideas about this
child tax credit family medical leave
child care so many so many issues thank
you
to the ways and means committee the list
goes on we're also joined by
distinguished chair and vice chair of
the caucus
congress mr chairman hakeem japaris vice
chair
peter aguilar and the chair of our d
triple c
who knows why we have to make sure the
american people get the message
because it is in their interest with
that i'm very pleased to yield to the
distinguished
distinguished
i have to say it right chuck said i
didn't say it right yesterday
distinguished
democratic leader majority leader of the
house denny hoyer
[Music]
well thank you very much good morning
everybody
the speaker said it the last time the
economy grew at this pace and it was so
good
ronald reagan said it was good morning
in america
what an extraordinary first uh
seven months we've had in the congress
of the united states
we infamously started out with a tragedy
for our democracy
and yesterday we dealt with that in a
bipartisan way
extraordinary amount of work done uh the
congress on behalf of the american
people
and one of the most important things
we've done is enacting the american
rescue plan reached out
and lifted up millions tens of millions
hundreds of millions of americans
the economy shows that economic numbers
show the impact of this law is
having substantial positive effect
with the economy growing at its fastest
pace in four decades
that law directed resources to speed up
vaccinations
allowing for the safe reopening of
businesses in schools we're turning
millions to work
nearly 70 percent of the adults in our
country are now
at least partially vaccinated we need
more
much more we need everybody to become
vaccinated
but we provided for quick access
and universal access now everybody needs
to take advantage of it
nearly half of our total population is
fully protected but we see
today that that is not enough and the
president is urging and we are urging
more unfortunately some of our
colleagues
for too long said it really wasn't
necessary more than 300 million
vaccinations have taken place since
president biden
took office that is a success
and one we need to keep building on as
we work to get
every american vaccinated the law also
provided another round of direct
payments that have helped keep families
afloat
with 171 million
direct payments going out the door
lifting not only those 171 million
people but our economy the american
rescue plan also launched the expanded
middle class tax cut we call also the
child tax
to make sure that children can make it
in america are lifted up in america
as a result of that action 30 million
american families received their first
monthly payments in july
of 300 for each child under 6 and 250
for each child
from 6 to 17. with a lump sum payment of
the balance when the file taxes next
year
they will mean thirty six hundred
dollars for each child
and under six and three thousand for
children ages six through seventeen
twenty twenty one that is prioritizing
children in america this middle class
tax cut
is having a real impact on families
helping them afford
everyday expenses and to purchase goods
which helps the economy across the
country more than 4
million children will be lifted out of
poverty by this
expanded child tax payment to families
and it's projected to cut the child
poverty rate
by as much as a half
that's god's work it's the people's work
the american reserve rescue plan with
the child tax credit
is making a transformational investment
in the lives of children
and the families across america i'm
extraordinarily proud
of what we've achieved a lot of
legislation that the american people
were told that we would do
has been done it sits in the senate
and hopefully it will be adopted to the
benefit of the american people now i
want to introduce
my good friend the whip who has been so
critical to the success that we've had
in the house of representatives
on passing this historic legislation jim
clyburn of south carolina
jim i thank the leader
for yielding i thank the speaker for the
tremendous leadership
that she's given to this caucus and i
thank all
of my colleagues here who have been so
good on all of these issues i'll cheer
our assistant speaker the chairs
of our various committees i think we saw
on yesterday
already reports today of what happened
in georgia
on yesterday involving
the issue of voting among the things
that we have done
we've passed hr1 and we sent israel one
to the senate
and the senate is now exerting
its will as it relates to that language
we have not yet passed hr4
and i want to speak to that because some
of the reporting
of that is not quite
accurate uh hr4 was basically
uh a renewal of rio or getting beyond
or trying to get beyond the supreme
court decision as it relates
to the 1965 uh voting rights act
uh nine years ago in shelby v holder
uh the supreme court said to us that the
formula
uh in section four that triggers uh
pre-clearance of section five was
outdated
and we needed to redo the formula
uh the speaker then authorized uh
several uh people to uh
go about the business uh of uh updating
the formula
now when you deal with that you got to
go out you got to get the
facts and you put that all together
and we've done it both the committee
that gk butterfield uh who's
working with they've had all of their
hearings
uh they've developed a record uh
judiciary committee chaired by jared
nadler
they've had theirs and they are now
putting all that together and we expect
by next week uh they will uh
lay out we hope on the anniversary date
of the signing of the 1965
voting rights act which was august 6
1965
uh several months after bloody sunday
and so
that's the date that we uh have decided
to rule out a trial for now
hr 4 then goes to the senate
we have heard with all of the
negotiations we've had with various
people
uh that there is even republican support
uh for hr4 how much republican support
we don't know
uh but we do believe that we have a very
good
product and there are two things we have
to keep in mind
when we talk about voting rights
number one the original 1965 voting
rights act
dealt with a history of discrimination
and that's why that act was what six
states were the targets and therefore
we had to have it narrowly tailored
and uh we had to justify
it with this record however there's
tremendous sentiment
in our caucus for
expanding pre-clearance to all 50 states
and that is because 48 states have
either
proposed or passed 48 states have
proposed and i think 28 states have
already passed
restrictive laws which means that a lot
of those states would not be
covered because they did not have a
history of discriminating
they have just taken that on as a new
place to be uh
when it comes to voting and so we have
to
be prepared uh for a state like
pennsylvania
uh that is expressing some onerous ideas
uh
about voting going forward so uh i am
very pleased with the work that we've
done
with hr one and with hr4
uh i think uh that we will
have a product uh going to the senate
uh by uh next week this time
uh we'll test they'll be required
that these yield uh
and thank you speaker pelosi and leader
hoyer and the incredible leaders behind
me
for delivering these historic and
life-changing wins for the american
people
this week ably led by our fair woman
rose
de laura house democrats passed nine
major funding bills that not only
confront the challenges that we face
but will build a more equitable
sustainable future
this bold funding package puts
american families front and center
exactly where they should be we're
making health care
more affordable and feeding hungry
children and families
we're getting people back to work and
creating thousands
of good paying green jobs with
investments
in clean energy and science we're
tackling the housing crisis
through 125 000 new low-income
vouchers we're acting to prevent
domestic violence in helping survivors
and confronting sexual assault and
harassment in the military
we are making unprecedented investments
in our children and child care including
head start
and for the first time in decades we're
standing up
for health care for all women and their
constitutional rights
by repealing the hyde and helms
amendments and global
and domestic gag rules the last 18
months have been so challenging
i don't have to tell anybody about that
but we are meeting as the house
democratic caucus
these historic challenges with historic
progress
our message to the american people is
simple
we see you and we are building an
economy
that includes you from the american
rescue plan to the funding package
and next through infrastructure we are
rebuilding our economy with equity at
the center
and with jobs and opportunity
as our promise we will ensure that every
american
every woman and child has a fair shot
at success thank you it is a good
morning indeed and i yield back
thank you so much uh listening to our
leadership
go over so many of these things i think
it would be important to put
an exclamation point on some of this uh
starting with the child
tax credits
about the children and sonny referenced
it's about
children
it's about the he has floor duty about
the children
mr neil would you like to put an
exclamation point on all of this
sure i mean i thought thanks to the
speaker for her leadership by a reminder
of
how good things were 17 months ago and
we stepped outside of her office
just past midnight with our fur plan and
then the heroes act that
she largely authored after the cares act
which saved the american economy in the
president's rescue package
when you you think of what was
accomplished including
the child credit which we expanded now
into more middle class households across
the country
it's going to have a profound impact and
clearly to sit in the
oval office with the president and say
to him we're going to include the child
credit he said we're going to i'm going
to support you
and to talk about the dependent care
credit
ate only medical leave
there are two million people across
america who sleep every night now
knowing that their pensions are not
going to be lost
because of the multi-employer pension
plan
progress that we put forward so we made
it possible for people
to simultaneously increase demand
because supply will certainly follow
there's a base phenomenality
i can't tell you how extraordinary it is
when you pick up that times report
yesterday morning to say that poverty
rates have been cut in half
just because of the work that we've done
and when you continue
as steny pointed out 170 million people
receive
direct benefits from the federal
government there's a role for government
in our lives and the direct intervention
of the federal government
on three successive occasions have
helped turn around this economy
22 million jobs were lost and now we're
back to pre-pandemic levels
that's i think what we are acknowledging
today but it was the work of
the democratic caucus patience but not
to miss the point how important it is
to have a democrat sitting in the white
house
that was a somewhat what the the
distinguished chairman mentioned
happened early in the administration of
joe biden
part of that rescue plan was the work of
the energy and commerce committee
mr chairman do you want to brag about
some of what's there and what's to come
well i'll just mention two points
relative to health care
first of all you know during the whole
time
of the cova crisis while donald trump
was president
we were constantly hearing complaints
about
lack of supplies uh inability to get
help whether it was testing vaccines
hadn't started then
to the american people and all that has
just completely turned around
uh since joe biden and since
the democrats have been in the majority
in both houses and
in washington and if you look at the
american rescue plan
in terms of the money that went out and
the way that we've been able to handle
the covet crisis i mean i know that it's
not we're not totally there yet
we have the delta variant and we still
are wearing masks
but the bottom line is we don't have
those supply chain problems
more and more people keep getting
vaccinated more of the vaccine gets out
it's it's it's really now a problem of
getting people to
to take the vaccine not that it's not
available it's generally available
so i think that there's been a real
change in terms of
our ability to handle uh this pandemic
and make significant progress and then
the other thing i would say is as health
insurance you know in the american
rescue
plan we made permanent um the subsidies
and the help for people to pay
for their health insurance and the
number of people that have signed up
for obamacare or the affordable care act
is unbelievable huge numbers huge
increases
part of that is because we had the
outreach you know we did
the advertisement and we did everything
to make people sign up
but also because of the subsidies which
were significantly expanded
and so we just want to continue that if
you if you look at
what's being proposed in the
infrastructure bill
whether it's health related or it's in
terms of creating jobs and
addressing some of the other
infrastructure concerns we're just going
to build
on these successes i think that we're at
the point today where we can take
a victory lap if you will for all that
we've done but also make a commitment to
the american people about
how much more we're going to do thank
you madam speaker
well in this time of olympics i like the
victory lap
comparison again chronologically next we
did the invest
act of which we are very very proud i
spoke
earlier about the credentials that mr
mr defazio brings to this subject i
would like to yield
the podium to him
well thank you madam speaker uh before i
go to the invest act i'd like to point
out some of the things in the rescue
package you know
a lot of people are complaining today
because the the planes are full
uh they're crowded uh there wouldn't be
many planes in the air today
uh if we hadn't done uh you know the
numerous uh
packages to save the up to a year a year
and a half for them to get recertified
to fly a plane again flight attendants a
minimum of
three to six months much longer probably
so uh
we uh that was tremendous we also uh
saved the transit industry you know
people are now starting to go back to
work
they're starting to move around more uh
transit wouldn't have been ready and
wouldn't be there
if we had not supported the transit
agency through these
these packages so those were incredible
things that we tend to forget about we
did them
we saved them you know what so what no
those were amazing things that we did
that wouldn't have happened without the
democrats
uh running the house now the the invest
act
uh you know i set out an objective to
deal with our crumbling infrastructure
uh to deal with it in a way that also
dealt with climate change to create
millions of good-paying jobs to reach
into areas that
have persistent poverty uh you know
provide new
transit options uh you know a whole host
of things i'm not going to
uh really you know regurgitate all that
again
right now we have not yet seen a bill
out of the
senate so i can't particularly comment
on it
i have been engaged though with my
colleagues my democratic colleagues
who have chairs of jurisdiction and with
the white house just yesterday
and i'm expressing a strong desire that
should the senate
pass a bill uh that we should conference
that bill
and work out our differences we've
already passed a major bill in the house
it has all the objectives
that the president and the white house
sent set out for me
and i want to make certain that they're
in the final package so that would best
be accomplished through a conference
thank you mr defazio and now uh up until
last night we were on the floor with our
appropriations bills mr hoyer mr clyburn
ms clark
and i are all um appropriators so we
have some good judgment about what uh
uh how to pass a appropriations bill
rosa de lauro set a higher standard that
we ever knew
and we thank her with madam chair thank
you
thank you madam speaker and thank you
very very much uh for your leadership
and
uh our work together with regard to
appropriations and i say that
uh with regard to all of my colleagues
uh as we've made our way over the last
several months in the last 17 months
just to say a word before
appropriations it's really thrilling uh
that
with your work madam speaker the work of
chairman neil
that we have a child tax credit that is
going to be a lifeline to the struggling
middle class as well as lifting
55 of of children out of poverty in this
nation and that is a transformation
uh and it is social security as you've
quoted uh
madam speaker social security for
children uh and we could do
um well we can do more we need to make
it permanent but there we go
but i'm very very excited about we
passed
nine appropriations bills and
in addition to that the uh security
supplemental bill
so uh and the focus of those bills was
to make america stronger at home
and again respected uh uh in in in the
world and
this is we looked at what we needed to
do and looked at what the state
of our country was and decades of
disinvestment
devastation from the pandemic and the
time we
believed was now to reinvest in the
american people
and the bills make historic increases in
critical funding
with the goal of creating good paying
american jobs
to grow opportunity for the middle class
for our small businesses
and to provide that lifeline to working
families
and to the vulnerable i may add that i'm
also very very proud of the work that
was done
uh and i i might add in a bipartisan way
on community projects
uh we're bubbling up from our
communities
where members sat with their uh city
councils they sat with their non-profit
groups
and they came forward with the kinds of
critical needs
that we could try to address through
this process and it happened
we have made investments in education
and nutrition
rural and underserved communities um
rebuild the
nation's infrastructure confront the
climate crisis uh again with regard to
good paying jobs
protecting our democracy looking at the
disparities
advancing equal treatment for women
fostering a brighter future for the
people in this country
and we yes we have reinvested in
diplomacy and development
and reasserting american global
leadership so
our caucus has demonstrated tremendous
leadership
in passing these very important bills
and i look forward
to work with the senate so that we can
act enact them into law
and with that i don't know
it's important to note that for what 10
congress is now 20 years
rosa de laurel has been introducing the
child tax credit
legislation and so uh
and and
mr neil has uh uh has been a partner in
all of that
uh but as far as rose is concerned as
usual she was persistent dissatisfied
and relentless and the children benefit
to make it known to the public build the
consensus in our
our caucus our distinguished leadership
of the uh
uh house caucus mr hakeem jeffries and
uh
pete aguilar who is an appropriator as
well um
have given us a forum to build that
consensus and our distinguished
chair uh sean patrick maloney he has
is trying to convey that message to the
american people so that people will take
advantage
of the opportunities that are there they
and all of our chairs stand ready
to answer any of your questions
questions
yes on the issue of ma'am rights can you
tell us a little bit more about your
meeting with president biden today
and more specifically uh when is it
and uh also if you can tell us if you do
have hr4 ready next week when you intend
to bring it up on the floor
well mr clyburn has addressed this very
thoroughly because
thank you for your question this is of
the highest priority for us
the sanctity of the vote the basis for a
democracy and the assault on the
democracy that is being
uh perpetrated across the country and
states across the country
to suppress the vote uh in a way
that just undermines the strength of our
democracy
uh we i have not seen the uh
what has been circular my understanding
is there's something
that the senate has put together i
myself have not seen it because
uh i was doing our other work and uh i
will see it
uh our hope with the uh white house well
we'll see
it's the president's meeting and so it's
his agenda uh but uh
it is uh well known to the
administration and to the united states
senate
that the hr one is essential
to us in the house because it is
fundamental to our democracy
mr clyburn i think went into some detail
about what august 6
is it's fraught with meaning as the
anniversary of the first voting rights
act being passed in 1965
uh and that our goal is to be ready
with something uh what happened was that
the supreme court
said that our as mr clyburn mentioned
that we had to have our formulas updated
we didn't think so
but they're the supreme court so we
wanted to make the next presentation of
the bill
ironclad constitutionally and we were on
a path to do that
until just a few weeks ago the court
again made an assault
on the voting rights act on section two
and so
um that we had to go back to make some
modifications
i feel confident that we will be ready
as soon as ready
we will bring it to the floor yes sir
madam speaker uh these two these seats
here have some kind of advantage so you
you all should know that i no offend is
that anybody back
madam speaker should immigration excuse
me sir
mr clyburn did you want to add anything
on the voting anybody
does it get jefferson no no no okay
okay thank you madam speaker madam
speaker
should immigration reform being a budget
reconciliation bill
and if it is and the senate
parliamentarian rules it out should
senate democrats overrule the
parliamentarian
to make to include it well i'll just
address the first part and yield to mr
aguilar to speak to that
he has been a real leader on this issue
and working very hard
on it uh i do believe that immigration
should be in the reconciliation some
piece of that in the reconciliation
i never go into senate rules mr aguilera
and and i don't think i'll go into
senate rules either um
yesterday i was pleased you know chair
lofgren and
uh chair nadler as well as chair durbin
um
and chairman menendez and a group of
others
um in the white house to talk to the
president about this and to
reiterate our support for reconciliation
uh including uh immigration proposals
we should be guided by and i know that
shares and the people behind me
you know speak to this as well we should
be guided by providing
the greatest good for the greatest
number of people in our country and so
including a path to citizenship for
those with daca status
tps essential workers and those farm
workers
bipartisan bills most three of those
proposals
bipartisan bills that this house has
passed under the leadership of the
speaker
the leader in the whip and so that's
what we should be guided by
and and that's the the president's
commitment um is that he will continue
to support he will speak out on this
um we appreciated it um and and without
speaking to the to the senate
discussion um uh you know we're gonna be
guided by providing
a path of citizenship for uh those in
our country
um who know of uh who this is their
country as the
as the speaker has said time and time
again thank you
just for your information i'm sure most
of you know this
but uh the to qualify for uh being
included
in a reconciliation bill the proposal
has to have an impact on the budget
we have clear numbers to that effect
to go forward so again without going
into how the senate considers something
significant or not we won't go into that
and what the senate should do if not
but we know we have a very good case
for this to be included
you said in your letter last night it's
a moral imperative
for congress to extend the eviction yeah
are you frustrated that the
administration
took so long to make that ask of
congress is it your
uh i'll be happy to answer that but
let's stay on subject here and then i'll
come back to that okay
any questions on uh our agenda i know uh
some of our other colleagues want to
weigh in on that yes i was hoping to get
more clarity on voting rights i heard mr
clyburn say i think that we will have a
product going to the senate by next week
this time that will meet the tests that
are required
does that mean there will be a house
bill and will you bring the house back
for a vote
mr clyburn would you like to speak to
them
well patreon or the john r lewis
voting rights and advancement act is
what we renamed it
has you know the last the last year
was based upon issues that we were
aware of and that were before us as the
speaker said
two weeks ago i guess it was the supreme
court issued another
opinion on the voting rights act of 1965
and so therefore uh we are including
our language as to what will fix that
as well as what will get us to where we
are to be
on pre-clearance now uh i know we are
supposed to be out next week
uh but um i also
am realistic enough to know that we may
not be out
next week or the week following it so we
are going to get this bill prepared
hopefully announce what it is
on august 6 a bill that can
go to the senate when it goes to the
senate it's when we get a chance to vote
on it
and may i just say let's not get
ourselves
um too concerned about a date the date
of
august 6 is so important to us fraught
with so much meaning historically
so much pointing to the need for us to
uh perpetuate what was
uh when that first bill but uh when it
is ready
is when we'll call members back and what
when it's ready is when
we aren't clad constitutionally and i
salute the
distinguished whip and the members who
are working
on this very important piece of
democracy other issues like
nullification of election
there are other things that we have to
deal with in the uh hr one
beyond what was in it originally because
in the last election and since then we
have seen further
undermining of the vote
well we're going to continue to move
forward thanks to the leadership of
speaker pelosi
and jim clyburn and others uh in
addressing
the attack on democracy and the voter
suppression epidemic
with the fierce urgency of now
including dealing with the most recent
supreme court decision as the speaker
and the whip
have illustrated at the same time we're
going to continue to make
tremendous progress for
the american people
the biden economy is growing at the
fastest
rate in 40 years millions of good-paying
jobs
have been created a massive middle-class
tax cut has been enacted
democrats are doing our damn thing
and we're just getting started for the
people
thank you where this the rubber meets
the road where the rubber meets the road
on boating is of course
in the elections and i wanted to have
our distinguished chair
of our uh d triple c of mr sean patrick
maloney by the way
today is his birthday he's 55 years old
i told him this morning in a conference
that we had with
members that in in the casino
55 is called hard way 10. anybody if you
go to casinos now
and if you go to casino hard way 10
because you can get a soft ten
six and a four there's a six and a four
on each die
there's only one five on each die 55
hard way 10 happy birthday hard way 10.
it's hard way 10 but a glorious cause
for celebration for the rest of us
mr sean patrick ford just when you think
you don't know every wrinkle of the
speaker's extraordinary talent
when i think of the speaker i think of
being on a heater in las vegas yeah but
i
and i have now discovered that the title
of the book we're going to write
together
on why we won this election it's going
to be called hard way 10.
for the american people uh well look
you've heard my colleagues um
speak in detail about how democrats are
delivering strongest economic growth
in 40 years a middle-class tax cut
giving families back their own
money to help families and an
infrastructure plan
investing in american infrastructure to
bring our jobs back grow manufacturing
stop sending jobs to china
be less dependent on foreign energy and
grow this economy
even more and the only point i'll add to
what my
colleagues have said is that every
republican
voted against the economic growth plan
that is producing the greatest growth in
40 years
every republican voted against that
expansion of middle-class tax cuts
that is giving families their own money
back and we're going to find out where
they are
on infrastructure and so while democrats
are delivering
the republicans have have told two
dangerous lies
these are the evil twin towers of
deception
a lie about the election which led to
the attack on this capital which they
are now trying to ignore
and a lie about the vaccine which is
making harder our efforts to end this
pandemic
and get our lives back the republican
party has become
deceitful and dishonest
dangerous and divisive but democrats
are delivering thank you thank you so
much
any other questions on the great
accomplishments of the democrats in the
first six months seven months of this
year
you had one right
[Music]
i'm happy to come back here on on this
subject that we're here for
on the child tax credit uh are you
confident that there will be an
extension of the tax credit in any
reconciliation bill and would that be
through 2025
or a permanent extension and would that
come with any additional aid for the irs
to implement it
i can guarantee you that irs enforcement
is going to be in the next package
any one of my constituents if you said
to them if you spend 40 dollars we'll
give you 140 back
my constituents get it and what's
happened
is that the irs no longer has the
capacity
in terms of technology and or man and
woman power
to do the sort of sophisticated audits
that are now required
i heard a statistic the other day i hope
you'll all zero in on which tells the
whole story
the compliance rate in terms of tax
reporting in america generally hovers
between 82 83
84 and a good year 85 percent of the
american people
they pay their taxes for wage earners
because of withholding it's 99
that's the difference so for those of
you who are paid in wages like
i know most of you are
it's easy the irs collects but now it's
more sophisticated
avoidance and in some offshore addresses
it's about evasion and there's a
distinction between the two i know
because in subtle law you
you approach it differently the child
credit
my intention is to make it permanent uh
i must tell you the reviews are
extraordinary so far and i think part of
it is because of the
expansion of income levels for people
who could secure that and the other part
of it has not been
really reported some of the christian
conservative groups in america are
really
fine with this they're pretty happy
about it they tend to vote on the other
side but they like this
as an initiative so i i think as we go
forward the two questions you've asked
i hope i've been answered just very very
quickly
madam speaker as as the chairman said it
will be
a part of the reconciliation bill but it
is already a part
of the financial services and government
appropriations
uh subcommittee which we just passed uh
in the minibus
yesterday there is increased funding
for the irs both for enforcement and for
the implementation
of the child tax credit and we are told
by the irs
one is that we leave about a trillion
dollars on the table
uh because of their over the years the
inability for them to have what they
needed with technology and staffing
uh to make up that to make up that
difference
and if you think about it it's a
trillion dollars in
what child poverty costs us in this
country and so
what we want to try to do is to make
sure they have the tools that they need
to both enforce and to implement
thank you i just want to say that again
coming back to the children the child
tax credit the many other things that
we've had in
past legislation in the uh rescue
package but that
need to be even more so in the
reconciliation
the congresswoman assistant speaker
clark has been a champion on child care
child care
child care so when we say build back
better we're saying build back better
with women child care now not that
gentlemen don't
men don't dads don't benefit from the
child care
money as well child care family and
medical leave
early childhood education
universal pre-k that is issues that
relate to home
health care workers to liberate people
from their responsibilities at home in a
way that they can go to work
pursue their careers knowing that their
family members
are safe so there's so many things about
the human infrastructure
that is in that bill in addition to the
child tax credit which is
so remarkable thank you for your leader
sibling
she's she relentless to satisfy
persistent
on on the subject one last question then
i'll go to yours
yeah my question is on that exactly um
because millions of people right now of
course are holding their breath as
they're watching this eviction
moratorium expire
were you caught off guard by the white
house's statement
not to extend it and why did democrats
wait until now
hours before recess ends hours before
this eviction moratorium is going to
expire
to try and hold a vote to extend it
excuse me any questions
comments on what has gone before my
college
any closing remarks okay uh
we're in a situation where the pandemic
has
of course taken its new shape as we've
talked before these
uh viruses are um resourceful uh they
when they are transmitted they mutate
and that makes it more of a challenge
we know that that is what we are faced
with now and so
the the center for disease control has
talked in a new way about again about
mask wearing about
that urging vaccination and the rest of
the
moratorium for eviction is a covet
initiative
related to the uh intensity of the issue
and for 46 billion dollars
was um allocated both in the year-end
omnibus
uh last december as well as in the uh
rescue package 46 billion dollars
this money has largely gone out to the
states and local governments
to implement and to give to the renters
so they can pay the rent
which helps the landlords of course too
and uh the fact is that
almost 50 billion dollars was allocated
46 billion dollars
less than 10 percent that is a
three billion dollars is reported to me
but let's say
it would be 10 why should the
uh the ranchers be punished for the fact
that
the system did not put money in their
pockets to pay
the rent uh to um uh to the landlords
so that's where we come to this is like
well cdc
you have defined this and
these people have not gotten the money
so this is i think this is something
that will
work out it isn't about any more money
the money is there resting in localities
and
governor's offices across the country so
we would like the cdc
uh to uh expand the moratorium that's
where it can be done
and then and of course with the public
message of
governors mayors etc give the money for
its purpose uh to the renters so this is
uh
this is uh to me a very an imperative
that it be done
and uh
as i say time is not everything on the
except
that the moratorium ends but
again if if they know that the money
will be released
then we'll go there there are all kinds
of talking lawyers who saw this and that
uh and the executive branch i don't know
i don't want to be critical of what
because they just made the statement
yesterday
but we are uh we're not going
to or thereafter
uh it is i mean have you ever seen
an eviction sometimes even the law
enforcement people
go into these apartments are crying
because they know they're going to do
something that's going to put
babies crips out on the street personal
belongings
on the street it happens like that
passers-by can even take that stuff
these people have been evicted
now have to find another place to live
to take this stuff that's now been on
the street
it is the most heart-wrenching and so in
defiance
everything that we say we are about in
the gospel of matthew
when i was knitted shelter you you gave
it to me that the words of the lord
so i think that this is something that
fairness and justice has to be done
will ensure that it does thank you all
very much
today madame do you think the
administration can extend it
i think is
okay
is
so
okay um thank you all for coming
um conquerors and congressman cuellar's
at
28th district henry so i just was on a
phone
uh call with uh with henry uh with
people from his congressional district
police chiefs ngos mayors
and it's pretty bad um
congressman cuellar has done everything
he knows to do
to try to get the nation's attention to
the
problems facing the 28th congressional
district in texas
we're letting you down the nation as a
whole
is letting you down what's going on
in your district is bad for the country
uh only god knows what the illegal
immigrants
experience getting to our country
and the people who live in your district
are literally
under siege and i'm gonna have henry
start this off by explaining the nature
of the problem
i spent about 45 minutes listening
to all aspects of the community in the
28th district
i will be going down there trying to
help you
fix a problem that affects everybody
else in america
because most of the people that come
through your congressional district
are sent to the interior of the united
states so it really is a problem for all
of us
but finally i just want to say i've been
here for quite a while now since 1995.
i've never known anybody who is willing
to speak
truth to the power better than you henry
we have a democratic administration
tried to work with president trump i had
my dustups but
you've done it in the right way you've
been respectful
but i want to be an ally and trying to
get some relief to the people of your
district
so senator thank you uh
thank you so much i look forward working
with you i appreciate all the good work
you've always done on immigration reform
and
uh i really appreciate it i look forward
to working with you going down to the
district too
also um we just had a phone call because
i've always told the administrators look
i'm a democrat it's a democratic
administration
and i've been very respectful about the
administration all i said look you don't
have to listen to me
and i listen to the men and women of dhs
their families uh this weekend i just
spent about three hours with
agents and their families so the chiefs
are um
and especially their families uh and
they don't need pets in the back they
need uh
help down there on the border uh today
uh
we had a phone call and i want to thank
the senator and the staff for being
there
because i want people to hear from my
local communities i want you to hear
so we had folks from hidalgo county
which is where
most of you know the effie center is we
had a county judge county commissioners
mayors police chiefs and uh and
other folks there we went to stark
county same thing county judges
commissioners
cities uh mayors sheriffs zapata and of
course hidalgo and you heard
and i mean laredo you heard webb county
and and the mayor
uh is very passionate of mayor science
and other folks chief londina and other
folks
so i want people to hear from the local
communities and again look
um this are and i emphasize mainly south
texas hispanic
democratic elected officials saying
we need a pause and we need some help
down here
uh at the border we're very
compassionate we understand
most of us you know come from families
from mexico
uh you know my father was a legal board
of mexico guerrero tamalipas became a
legal resident
become a naturalized citizen they follow
our procedures and what they see there's
a
under underground attention
in many ways in the hispanic community
saying holy
we follow this procedure we follow the
steps
and we're seeing people just come in and
i think you heard
from folks that were saying also hey
we're concerned about this over capacity
what is the
end game here you heard about how
they're going to
parks and so when families want to go
out there what do we happen
you saw what happened in la jolla where
they released people without even
saying and it was not border patrol it
was a local ngo
and not telling the folks in la jolla
what was happening down there
and you hear there you know you hear
about safety concerns
roma texas as you know in stark county
it's right at the border i'm very
familiar that's part of my district la
jolla is part of my district
uh and you know people cross and they're
walking through the streets and
neighborhoods and they're saying hey
people are just walking through you
heard from
some of the school officials say hey
what about our schools and they have
been
locked down in schools because they're
right at the border and people started
just coming through and they worried
about their kids so
and again i've always said this uh if
you've heard me said you don't have to
listen to me
they don't have to listen to me the
administration doesn't need to listen
i've been very respectful very
supportive
of the administration but something has
to change
uh when it comes to uh border
immigration uh
issues uh on that and uh and again
we had the border patrol chiefs uh we
heard from chief ortiz
uh you heard about how hospitals are
overloaded like
as mayor uh science said hey sometimes
you have to pit
a undocumented person that goes to a
hospital with somebody that lives in
laredo
or somewhere else i mean you know
there's limited spaces
what do you do and it's not fair to put
a undocumented person
to a u.s citizen and you know we
represent
you know our residents and citizens here
so this or
i i think you know i'll close on this
and i'll
i'll let you talk about the letter we
have uh you know we we
we put a joint letter together uh and
i'll let the senator and i'll follow up
on that but i
i thought it was important uh for the
senator to hear
directly from the communities and how
they
feel about this you want to talk about
it
thank you very much and uh to to the
members of the press are here
thank you uh this is a story that needs
to be covered
if this were the 28th congressional
district
figuratively the room would be full of
folks from all over the world
unvaccinated
you would have a hard time moving around
and i don't think people can
appreciate what's going on at the border
until you listen to the people who live
there
so we'll do another phone call and we're
going to stream this one
we're going to find a way so that if
you're interested in what's going on at
the border
you can hear from the people who live
through it so what have we come to
conclude
comprehensive comprehensive immigration
reform in my view
is still very much needed but you can't
legalize people
in my opinion until you first secure the
borders
i was involved in the gang of eight and
before that with senator kennedy mccain
um kyle and salazar in 2008
trying to secure the border pathway to
citizenship for the
illegal immigrant population or
non-felons
switching to a merit-based immigration
system to help our economy
going forward i still believe that but
the one thing i know
you can't do is provide legal status
without first
fixing the border because it will create
a run on the border like you've never
seen before
so this idea of putting daca in the uh
infrastructure package is a terrible
idea until you first
fix the border and i sponsored the daca
bill with senator durbin
i've told him i'm willing to work on a
small deal medium deal or large steel
but the first deal
is to bring relief and secure the border
so henry and i have come to conclude
it's now time for a new set of eyes
on this problem that the people in
charge
have had six months and it's getting
worse
and i'm not here to throw partisan
stones today
but something's got to give right so we
were
talking yesterday what could we do who
do we
trust who do we believe could help us
get out of this mess and we both cons
concluded almost instantaneously jay
johnson
jay johnson served with president obama
he was a democrat i have a lot of
respect for jay
he was general counsel at dod uh and he
dealt with
these issues as secretary so the bottom
line for me
is that we're urging president button
to create a special position to bring
order to chaos
put somebody in charge whose focus is
just on the border and all the
problems associated with it that would
have uh
credibility in the eyes of congress
that's jay johnson
i can promise you that most republicans
respect jay johnson
and if jay would be willing to do it and
president biden would build
would be willing to nominate him i think
you would find solutions pretty quickly
so that's what the letter's about
something's got to give
a new set of eyes so
what's causing this it was the
police chief i think who said this third
wave
of illegal immigration is brought to you
by washington dc
the pull factors
by policy changes
the new pull factors are too great for
any money to the northern triangle to
matter
i work with vice president biden to put
750 million dollars
into the system to help the northern
triangle countries
with a rule of law issues with their
economy
with their corruption problems i am
willing to invest more
but the root cause of this wave of
illegal immigration
is not a deterioration in the last six
months of the northern triangle
it is that we've changed our policies
where people all over the world believe
now is the time to go to america
illegally
because once you get there you're going
to stay now what did jay johnson do
on his watch we had a wave of
unaccompanied minors and families coming
from brazil
to take advantage of the asylum program
jay johnson got on a plane and flew back
with these people to brazil
he sent a signal to the source of the
problem that this is not the way to
enter
the united states we had a 188
000 people come across last month about
25 to 30 percent were not from the
northern triangle
every week that goes by the word spreads
throughout the world
that the border is now open if you can
get one foot in the united states likely
you're not going to leave
so what we're asking for
is for the administration to put
somebody new
new set of eyes in charge of this
problem
and working in a bipartisan way to
provide the resources
and the policy changes to have a time
out
so that when you catch our breath as a
nation give the people the laredo and
the surrounding
areas some relief now what did i learn
i learned it is hell on earth right now
in his district
given this problem that the hospitals
are full
that neighborhoods have hundreds of
people
every day walking through the
neighborhood crossing our border
illegally and it's very
unnerving that the police are
overwhelmed
that the coven numbers are increasing
that the border patrol is doing the best
they can
shout out for the border patrol i've
been to iraq and afghanistan i think 57
times
i've seen our men and women in the
military in action
under the most difficult circumstances
imagined
i would put the border patrol and
customs agents
who are dealing with this crisis on par
with them
they're incredibly dedicated americans
and i don't know how they go to work
every day what they see
in terms of small children the
overwhelming nature of this problem
i just don't know how they do it and i
want them to know
that henry and i consider you all and
your families american heroes so i've
sent
three letters one with uh
congressman cuellar to president biden
to put a new set of eyes on the problem
somebody we all trust jay johnson i hope
you will consider that mr president
and i stand ready to work with jay or
anybody else
that has a rational plan for it number
two
i've written a letter to dr fauci and
i'll give you a copy
i don't know what we should be doing but
i know this
i'm vaccinated i've tried to be a
responsible citizen
if you're not vaccinated you need to get
vaccinated because i think the risk to
you and your family
and the community goes down greatly i
think it is safe
and i think it is highly effective
how you control the covet problem in
america
must include an analysis of the border
we've had 50 000 people released in the
united states because the border patrol
ran out of capability and capacity to
hold them
they literally put them on buses and
shipped them throughout the country
i dare say any of them were tested
i dare say that the system at the border
uh is not controlling the problem
associated with cobia coming from other
countries and guatemala
the vaccination rate is less than one
percent
so i've got a letter to dr fauci as you
tell us what to do as a nation
you need to look at the situation at the
border and give us an opinion
as whether or not it makes sense what
we're doing
and let me tell you i think it makes no
sense
i have a german engineer who works for
bmw in south carolina
so germany invested heavily in the bmw
plan in greenville south carolina greer
south carolina
the man wants to go home to see his i
think mother or father somebody who's
critically ill
and i'm having to move heaven and earth
to get him
legally able to go back to visit his
mother in germany
i can't go to canada you can't go to
europe because of coded restrictions
but we're having 1.2 million people
cross our border
being detained with no rational policy
at all
probably the best thing for the german
engineers go down the border get
caught or probably send them to germany
this makes no sense it's dangerous
it needs to stop so dr fauci you need to
answer
my letter as to whether or not you
understand what's going on at the border
and what changes do we need to make if
any
to really deal with the covenant problem
because i think a super spread of event
of all
super spreading events is at our
southern border
to secretary marcus i wrote you a letter
last week
of the 1.2 million people who came here
illegally
how many of them have been tested how
many of them have been released
to the united states how many positives
were there and what system do you have
in place to ensure
testing what happens if somebody comes
up positive
and of the 1.2 million how many have
been allowed to stay in the united
states
and what protocols do we have to deal
with cope
to the ngo community in your district
and
their american heroes on the same
footing as the border patrol
the catholic charities and others are
giving refuge to these folks
they're being overrun and the system has
literally broken
we're creating a national security
nightmare for this country
it'd be very easy for terrorists to
integrate themselves in the flow of
illegal immigration
our border communities are under siege
the hospitals are full
the cops are having to do more than they
can possibly do
and it is now time to define the problem
and fix the problem count me in for
investing in
northern triangle countries as part of a
solution but the pull factors have to
change
and i just want to thank uh congressman
cuellar for having the guts
to speak truth to power to let the
administration know what's going on
on the ground and what's so sad for me
is i had a mask that said
mask up the border
i mean if you're really worried about
who should be wearing a mask you need to
fix the border
this is a border completely porous and
open when it comes to covalent
there are no protocols in place and the
capability of the border patrol
to manage the flow has just been lost
we've lost control of the border
in your district do you agree with that
yeah some
big problems okay i'll say that he says
big problems i say we lost control
so we'll be glad to take questions but
here's what's so sad for me
if i had a news conference taking a shot
at donald trump about anything this room
would be full
all of you not all of you a lot of you
have masks
you know you're doing what you think is
responsible for yourself and your
neighbor
we're putting the people in the 28th
congressional district at risk
we're putting their economy at risk
we're putting their health at risk
we're putting the future of their
children at risk because we've lost
control of this
issue controlling our border
and the covet problem as it relates to
illegal immigrant crossings
it is now time to work together
without you can blame
everybody for the last 20 years you can
blame me you can blame henry
we're trying but i'm not looking
backward i'm looking forward
and as i look forward i'll end with this
the mayor of laredo said
we're still pretty safe but i worry
about where we're going to be as a
community in the next six months
the police chief said the resources i
have
now are beyond my the problems i'm
having to deal with beyond the resources
but every passing day it gets worse
the catholic charities and other ngos
have said
without some help we broke we've reached
the breaking point
so i have listened to the people of the
28th congressional district
your congressman has been the most
effective voice in all of washington
about trying to find a way forward i
joined his cause
i stand ready to work with obama
administration democrats and republicans
but i will not i will not let this go
uh without one hell of a fight
questions but are we
[Music]
okay
[Music]
out it's been a little busy i've been
getting home about 11 o'clock look
look first of all we're not criticizing
anybody that deals with the border but
we do need a new set of ice
you know business is good all the time
hey let's bring an outside
uh person to come in and give us a new
eyes we've had a mortar star
if you recall we'd had roberta jacobson
in my opinion she did great in central
america being border i think that might
have been a little different
and she's not there we don't have a
border show we've had border stars in
the past
uh and i think bringing somebody like
jay johnson and i think you heard me
i've always said
jay johnson as the center and i we said
we agree on him
and he was compassionate but he followed
the law
and look and one of the things he did
and i know we had a lot of conversations
and you mentioned also
was that look you know if if if somebody
needs to stay here that has to stay
he stays but if somebody he or she has
to be returned he returned
we see images you know you can't just
talk about people coming over
but we see images of people coming in
has anybody ever seen
a single picture or video or image
of somebody being returned they don't
want to show that because
unfortunately they don't want to offend
the immigration activists
and i've always said it's good to have
immigration activists but you also have
border communities and you heard from
them directly
border communities and the men and women
of dhs so
what we're saying is you know jay
johnson would be we haven't talked to
him but
somebody like him would be good somebody
who has his credentials
uh would be good uh but in my opinion
uh and i think also the senator jay
johnson
understood it he wrote the playbook can
you think about it
and let me just say that i've been
involved in a bipartisan way trying to
fix this problem if they try to put
daca and the uh 3.5 trillion dollar
infrastructure bill it'll blow up any
hope of bipartisanship for a very long
time to come
i think what we should do is we should
have an asylum reform fix
people are coming here we we canceled
the remaining mexico pro
policy now people are coming here making
asylum claims and they're being released
and they don't show up
people have been released without a
court date 50 000 people guess what none
of them are showing up
i don't blame them i blame us so what
i'd like to do is repair
uh the asylum loophole plug it for a
while
try to find some ways to better secure
the border and for that maybe we can do
docking tps you just got to slow down
the flow
you got to have a out on these illegal
crosstalks you got to give these
communities along the border
some hope and breathing space before you
break them
and and you heard the border communities
i mean
i'm just reflecting uh i'm just a
mirror of what my communities are saying
i mean and you heard of it
i i have not said anything else that my
border community is a member of the
profile i gave you they're
you know again i want to get political
but they're democrats or hispanic mainly
they're americans but they're saying you
know forget about political party
we need help down here uh and and look
last week over twenty thousand
individuals uh
uh yesterday uh day before yesterday
there was a group of 509 people
uh in one group itself steph you wrote
about
the story about the 50 people on
prosecutorial discretion
uh last week it was actually 55 000
people
that basically people are being put on
the honor system
to show up on immigration with that i
don't think
the honor system should be the the
protocol that we you should use because
as you wrote
people are not showing up they're you
know they're not given a notice to
appear so
you have the notice to appear then you
have the prosecutorial discretion the 55
000
plus you have large numbers and i've
asked the administration
very respectfully what is the end game
what is the end game on this and i don't
know if they know the answer or maybe
they don't want to share it with me
what is the end game and as the senator
said
we got to look at push factors and we
got to look at pull factors
if you just focus on the push factors
down there we've invested
billions of dollars you worked on the
senate side here i worked with k
ranger uh republican from fort worth
on the 750 on the house side on the
appropriations
we've added billions of dollars to
central america but we still have people
coming in
push factors but the pull factors if a
coyote makes
uh charges six to eight thousand dollars
and use the lower number six thousand
we've had over a million people
somebody do the math and i'll tell you
how much money and that doesn't even
include the getaways
10 15 getaways and
if there's somebody making money out
there and it's the coyotes
so just adding on to the j johnson
you're not even sure if this is
something that he would want a role or
position that he would want so you have
another name in case
i'm open why did we do this because we
feel like we're running out of time
the problems don't get the points you
really can be almost impossible to fix
so we agreed on jay we probably should
have called jay but
it's symbolic if jay can't do it i
understand if he's willing to do it the
binding administration would be making a
mistake not to give him the opportunity
a new set of eyes and i don't care who
people voted for in the 28th
congressional district in 2020.
they voted for me though yeah well i
okay they voted for henry and if i lived
there i would vote for henry
so the bottom line is this is about the
future it's about a group of americans
on the border who are filling the brunt
of illogical policies
many have existed for decades they're
getting worse not better
senator i think you've made clear your
position on a pathway for daca and tbs
here but speaker pelosi today said she
supports immigration reform in the
reconciliation bill
it seems like this train is leaving the
station so what can you do
to prevent that from happening well
number one well it will do
it will destroy the ability for me to
sit down and fix this problem in the
future because here's what's going to
happen
speaker pelosi i respect her we've known
each other for a very long time
if you legalize anybody
in this environment without first
addressing
the pull factors in the broken border
you'll be sending a message to the world
look what they just did let's get there
we'll be in the next tranche
you will be adding jet fuel to a fire
not
one time have we ever suggested
legalization first
border security second
so there seems to be some confusion
about how specifically a path to
legalization could fit in the budget
reconciliation on one end you have
senator hickenlooper saying that it will
be a paid for
on the other hand you said you have
senators harper and cardin saying that
there's funding for it
chile garcia said yesterday that there's
a top-line figure of 126 billion dollars
so
um beyond sort of like the legalization
elements i know you're here to talk
about border security
how does these things fit together then
if you want border security say through
reconciliation
it would
right that needs to be abandoned when it
comes to illegal immigration
he's a democrat i'm a republican i think
i can buy into aid to the northern
triangle
so vice president harris it's not that i
disagree
that the conditions in the northern
triangle need to be addressed
vice president biden knows very well
that i was the go-to republican
to put into the senate bill the escock
bill
a 750 million dollar program to combat
corruption
improve the economy and help uh deal
with the underlying
push factors okay count me in for that
but if you just did that
and you didn't change the pull factors
more and more people are coming
outside northern triangle countries and
if you legalize somebody
without first dealing with the pull
factors you're going to have a wave of
new illegal immigration from all over
the world
we have never done legalization then
border
so my my belief is stop
the partisan process for legalization
see if you can find ways to deal with
the pull factors
sufficient enough to stop future flow
i will deal with the underlying uh push
factors
and we'll have a pathway to citizenship
for a group of people that are probably
very deserving
but you don't see any way to do that in
the current congress then given that
the i mean what everybody's saying right
now is that the only path forward for
legalization would be directly
reconciliation i i'm saying that's not a
viable pathway for it it makes the
problem
with the border security but you won't
do it through reconciliation because no
republicans going to vote for three and
a half trillion dollar socialist
document
now listen i have been i've got the hell
beat out of me i'm sure henry's getting
ill beat out him
by immigration activists it comes with a
job
the people in south carolina why are you
doing what you're doing for all these
years
i've got no problem with a pathway to
citizenship if we have if we fix the
underlying problem
i don't want another way so count me in
for giving the people who've been here a
very long time
a chance to stay here on our terms but
we need to make sure that that's the end
of it
that we secure our border we have a
logical immigration system
i have no animosity toward the illegal
immigrants coming
i have a lot of my heart breaks for what
i see
i mean can you imagine being in a
catholic charity
dealing with this day in and day out god
bless you can you imagine being a border
patrol agent
who has a couple of kids of your own i
mean i've been there enough to know
and so i'm just begging the bible
administration
let's call it time out get a new set of
eyes
let's put rational policies on the table
very quickly it's not
rational that i can't go to canada
because it may hurt the united states
coveted problem
and completely ignore a border that's on
fire when it comes to coping
it makes no sense that i can't go to
europe or a german engineer working
in south carolina can't visit their
family because we're worried about the
spread of coven if he goes back to
germany
and you completely ignoring a border on
fire when it comes to covet
and illegal crossings so that's got to
stop
and talk about border crossings um
and i agree with the senator look um
before kobe 19 there were
over 18 million mexicanos that would
come into the u.s
to spend over 19 billion dollars money's
for our stores money for our hotels and
restaurants and i talked to the
secretary
several times i've talked to cdc i
talked to dr anthony fosse i think dr
anthony fosse understands why can we not
over lift the border restrictions
so what people ask me in my district is
let me get this right so we're not
letting the legal visa
holders from mexico that spend billions
of dollars in the u.s over 19 billion
dollars a year
uh pre-pandemic numbers but you're
letting undocumented
in and i've asked the secretary why are
the legal visa holders a health issue
but the undocumented not a health issue
again i'm i'm for strong border security
i said it in the appropriations
uh on reconciliation you know i have a
different position from the senator and
i respect specific i want to see
bipartisan the last time we had
bipartisan
was ronald reagan and the democratic
congress they get amnesty i i don't
agree with amnesty i do not believe in
amnesty i can tell you that
but i want to see it bipartisan but
unfortunately we can't do it
i've been here not as long as you i've
been here 16 years
and we've been talking about uh
immigration i do want to say
immigration and we have to look at that
path i know it's political i prefer a
bipartisan approach and i know the
senator's been uh
very active in the gang of aid and other
folks on that but
you know we'll see what happens on that
and it depends on you know
what the parliamentarian says it's going
to depend on the senate side
i've asked crs they told me it's
possible but they're not the
the final decided it's going to be uh
the parliamentarians
would you do some point over ruling the
parliamentarian if they were uh
um i don't sit in the senate so i can't
answer that question
you mentioned the preference for um
citizens in hospital beds over
undocumented immigrants do you believe
that you represent the illegal
immigrants in your district
well look uh i tell you i represent the
residents here i represent that
yeah well let me let me finish uh i want
to treat the undocumented aliens
with respect especially the
unaccompanied kids i mean we treat those
kids like if they're out
treat them with respect but i'm telling
you in my communities and you heard
our mayor they were saying why are you
pitting
our citizens with undocumented that
might have to fight for us
a precious hospital bed why is the
administration they basically said
why are you pitting us we should not get
to that question
uh we should not get to that question
but you heard the mayor
it's not fair to be put in that
situation
by the administration yes ma'am all
right
because of the higher numbers of people
crossing the border it obviously
requires significant funds
from from both the department of
homeland security but also department of
health and human services have there
been any discussions
among members of congress about
providing additional funds in some way
some kind of supplemental
i think a supplemental on this issue
is warranted after hearing so what
changed for me
is i'd be willing to do a supplemental
apart from a sort of a universal fix
if you can show me we're headed in the
right direction but the people
in the 28th district need some help and
they need it now
so henry if you want to work on a
supplemental uh
count me in but for it to be successful
you got to show that we're headed in the
right direction
we're all worried about afghan
interpreters who risked their lives to
help america in a war that's been going
on for 20 years
we're pulling teeth to get the right
number of visas
we're doing the vetting process we've
spent a i think a billion dollars right
i'm just perplexed look how hard we're
trying to do it right with afghan
interpreter the best thing for the
afghan interpreter
is to pay somebody if they can afford it
go to the southern border and they're
here to stay
the bottom line is this is not rational
but we need help for the border
communities
now we need money into the system
they're being overwhelmed but that money
has to be part
of an overall plan to have a timeout
then we can discuss what to do in terms
of
citizenship and all the other
combinations
but i just want to let you know i
listened today for about 45 minutes
i didn't realize it was this bad uh
you shouldn't they're very compassionate
people i've tried to show some
understanding an
undocumented woman in this country
illegal immigrant woman that she's
assaulted she's afraid to go to the cops
because she might
there's no upside to this right there's
no upside to illegal immigration
the people are coming because everybody
would try to get the america if they
could
we just can't let everybody come this
way his father did it right
i want to expand legal immigration i
want to give those who've been here for
years working while we all look the
other way
a chance to stay on our terms but this
news conference is about a plea
to the administration and the congress
to get a new set of eyes
to work together not against each other
to fix a problem before it completely
gets out of hand
if you lived where henry lives
if you had to go through what they go
through every day
you would be thinking that nobody in
this country cares about you
well congressman cuellar is making it
uncomfortable
for the rest of us to look the other way
i don't represent texas i've talked with
center corning i've talked to senator
cruz
they want to be helpful in their own way
so henry if you want to put together a
supplemental
for border communities count me in and
we'll see if that would be the starting
point for a larger conversation
thank you let me just close up and say
senator
all i have to say pop line from
listening to our border communities
they said give us a pause let us catch
our breath
we need some help and we're asking
through the letter
is put a new set of eyes
and in a constructive way somebody that
has the experience
that can deal with the border um so
that's all we're asking for
thank you so much
thank you we'll see yeah
all right
you